another insisted the longer strand this
is this last she won't mind looks better
on you anyway hope your father's solid
it's my family sword well he come for it
completely well sure what's up ladies
and gentlemen welcome back to talking
Thrones
I know episode 6 was just accidentally
released by HBO in Spain and I know
everyone wants to talk about that right
now but I will not be releasing a video
on that just yet I am working on a video
about that episode but I will release
that on Sunday because it's going to
take a little bit more research to get
that one done but for now there is
something else I want to talk about that
I think is pretty significant to the
flood still I want to talk about the
Valyrian steel sword hearts Bane which
has been the ancestral Valyrian steel
sword of house Tarly for over 500 years
one of the very first videos I ever made
was about hearts bein around ten months
ago but a few things have happened since
then that I've opened up a few new
possibilities regarding the fate of this
great sword back in season six Samwell
Tarly was on his way to the Citadel in
hopes of training to become the next
maester for the Nights Watch but most
importantly he was hoping he could find
something there that could help Jon Snow
for when the time comes to fight the
night king as we all know Sam stopped at
his home in horn Hill and had a very
unpleasant reunion with his father
randyll Tarly Sam's father did
everything he could to embarrass Sam and
he showed everyone the family sword and
he said that it was in the family for
over 500 years
he said the sword should be passed down
to his firstborn son Samwell Tarly but
he said Sam would never wield Hart's
Bain after dinner in the middle of the
night Sam decided he was going to take
Gilly and the baby with him to Old Town
but before he left he took hearts Mane
off the mantle and has been with Sam
ever since many people believed randyll
Tarly would be very angry about this and
come looking for Sam and his Valyrian
steel sword when randyll Tarly came back
for Season seven people were sure he was
going to go to the Citadel and get the
sword back since he knew Sam was going
there but
never did in fact he never even
mentioned a sword again and Randall and
dick entirely ended up being burned
alive by drug on because they refused to
bend the knee to Daenerys Targaryen
now Sam has nothing to worry about and
he can essentially do whatever he wants
with this sword but what will Sam do
with it I think there were a few clues
in episode 5 that may lead to what Sam
will do with hearts Bane while Sam was
at the Citadel they received a raven
from Winterfell and they learned that
bran stark saw the army of the dead
heading for eastwatch-by-the-sea Sam
tried to plead to all the maesters there
that bran was telling the truth Sam even
told the archmaester that he had seemed
the dead for himself Sam said they
needed to get every maester there to
search the entire library to look for
things about the long night and maybe
that could give them a chance to defeat
the night King but the maesters didn't
take him very seriously so once again
Sam decided he was going to leave in the
middle of the night with Gilly and
little Sam before they left Sam went
into the library and he took all kinds
of documents scrolls manuscripts books
or whatever he thought could potentially
be useful he loaded everything up in the
carriage and he's heading to Winterfell
himself in hopes that he can be of some
help for when the time comes but if you
look closely you can see Sam still has
hearts bein with him wrapped up like
before so it's not like this sword has
been forgotten about in terms of the
plot I don't think Sam took it for no
reason and if you think about it all the
other Valyrian steel is going to end up
in the north where the fight against the
army of the dead will begin the Valyrian
steel dagger has all of a sudden popped
up in the north too and that's not a
coincidence either
but you have to wonder though what kind
of information could possibly be in all
these documents Sam stole from the
Citadel's library they have to be of
some importance - even if he doesn't
know it yet
we have all been wondering if Sam would
discover the methods to making Valyrian
steel and he could possibly have the
secret to making it in one of these
documents that he has with him you also
have to consider what type of sword
Hart's Bane is Hart's Bane is a
two-handed great sword which means it's
a very big sword it's not quite as wide
as ice but it's long so if Sam decided
to break hearts bang down and make it
into several weapons you could easily do
that since it's a two-handed sword the
only thing you would mean now is someone
who could reforge it and guess who all
of a sudden came back
to the story at the same time Sam is
heading to the north that's right that's
our favorite blacksmith Gendry tearing
and davos went to King's Landing so
Tyrion can meet with his brother Jaime
but Davos went looking for gentry
because he knew they were going to need
a blacksmith now that they are mining
all of this dragon glass now I know some
of you are probably going to say there
is no point of needing Hart's Bane
because John now has an entire mountain
worth of dragonglass and that's a very
valid point you don't need Valyrian
steel as much now since there is all
this dragon glass but you have to ask
yourself why did they have seen him
steal his father's sword if he wasn't
going to put it to use in some way they
may have an endless amount of dragon
glass but the Valyrian steel swords that
have been introduced in a show are
definitely going to be put to use one
way or another during the Great War
Davos also said something interesting to
Gendry that makes me think he will meet
Sam and they may reforge hearts paid
when Davos was bringing Gendry into the
cave to meet John Davos told Gendry to
keep his mouth shut about who he was and
then he told Gentry to tell John that he
just came to pay his respects to the
king then he was going to head off to
work at the Winterfell forges to make
weapons ginjury should be at Winterfell
making weapons right now but he told
John the truth and he ended up going on
the mission beyond the wall with John
but when Kendra gets back from that
mission he is going to be heading to
Winterfell next to make weapons like he
agreed he would do when Kendra gets to
Winterfell this is where he is going to
meet Samwell Tarly and I can't say for
sure what Sam will do with arts bane but
I don't think Sam is going to be using
that sword himself
Sam has killed a white Walker before but
it wasn't like Sam went toe-to-toe with
him Sam got lucky and was able to stab
him in the back fighting a white Walker
face-to-face is a completely different
story something I don't think Sam wants
to do but hey who knows Sam could end up
wildung the sword just out of spite
because Randall did say Sam would never
wield hearts pain so maybe he does that
just to prove to himself that he can but
I think the sword would be more
beneficial if used in other ways some of
you may or may not know this but when
Kendra started out as a blacksmith back
in season 1 he was actually working for
a man named Tom on top amant actually
knows how to reforge Valyrian steel
which means he can take Valyrian steel
when were forged it into different sizes
and several different weapons
very few people know how to do this but
ginjuries mentor had this skill now do
you think that's a coincidence because I
don't I think you may have taught Gendry
this skill also or at least told him the
method in which you can do it the long
night is on the horizon and every man
woman and child in the north needs a
weapon to fight the army of the Dead
Gendry will be heading there to make
weapons Sam is heading there now he has
a very large Valyrian steel sword in my
opinion it just makes sense that they
will do something with hearts bane but
let's say Sam doesn't have it reforged
Jon Snow does have his own suicide squad
now and they're all really good
swordsmen but John is the only one who
has Valyrian steel being the kind of man
Sam as I can see Sam giving his sword to
someone else to use during the Great War
and there are several really good
candidates that could end up with it in
John's new team I would love to see
tormund wield Hart's Bane in battle
torment has always been one of my
favorite characters and I'm praying he
makes it until the very end but I don't
know if torment would be the one to get
hearts Bane if Sam would let someone
else use it tormund really is a much of
a sword fighter he's more likely to
continue using some kind of battle axe
or some type of dragonglass weapon like
we have seen him carry in the trailer
photos
I think the Hound would be a really good
candidate as well he could easily wield
a two-handed sword and the Hound is
already a great swordsman as it is but
he doesn't have any Valyrian steel The
Hound did tell Brienne he has always
wanted some Valyrian steel so one day he
just might get his wish and have a
Valyrian steel sword of his own to use I
can already picture the Hound killing
White Walkers weight alongside Jon Snow
and even Brienne of Tarth but to be
honest with you I think the person who
has the best chance of getting Hart's
Bane has to be Jorah Mormont right now
Sam and Jorah have already built a
relationship with one another since Sam
cured his greyscale Jorah Mormont is
also a great swordsman too although he
has passed his prime
Jon Snow now carries house more mons
Valyrian steel sword but Jorah Mormont
could still end up with one by using
Hart's Bane I would prefer the Hound to
use it over Jorah Mormont but I think
Sam would give it to Jorah before he
would ever give it to the Hound but I
could be wrong about that
who do you see carrying Hart's bane into
battle now that Sam Tarly is heading to
Winterfell with the sword what do you
think he will do with it will gain
reforge it into several weapons or will
say and pass it off to a much better
fighter let me know your answer down
below and I'm going to finish my episode
6 video now and that will be uploaded by
Sunday I hope to see you all back here
for that one thank you all so much for
taking the time out of your day to watch
this one I really do appreciate that and
I also want to thank all my patreon
supporters too I love you all and I hope
you have a great day bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]